so today the theme of the lecture is
play like a pro right yes yeah
but I thought I would prepare a kind of
a funny theme of pros losing really
quickly and I had some threshold where
all the games were going to see our
games 15 moves or less for a strong
player loses and we're gonna start with
a game which Nakamura lost and wait let
me check the move number he lost in 12
moose actually I was watching this game
live and I was just being wildly
entertained because he he got pretty
crushed and it was played in the u.s.
Chesley which it which is now actually
the protest League but is played online
this was played back in 2009 it was game
I believe it was game 90 minutes now
it's it's much much more fast paced but
to losing 12 moves in a 90 minute game
as you'll see something went terribly
wrong so he was playing against
relatively strong GM Julio Becerra from
Florida and they went into a Sicilian
and sometimes Nakamura will do this
online will play very off beats
sometimes completely absurd or in this
case just dubious openings and here he
play the move which maybe some of you
just haven't seen before
he played Knight f6 so I wasn't seen
this move before you have maybe a few
people and I have six is not a popular
move against against efore and Knight f3
simply because but white can play e5 and
it's sort of combining the Sicilian with
the Alekhine but as we'll see white gets
some very nice leading developments so
Knight e5 is played and now Knight c3
simply wanting to trade off blacks
we develop peace and and open up the
center further so black plays d6
and I take d5 you take t5 and now I like
the move that Julio Becerra played d4
simply trying to open up the center when
all of lacks pieces are still in the
back row why already has a nice space
advantage and the bishops are ready to
develop very freely
so Nakamura plays knight c6 and now now
why it actually just wins a pawn here
a few guys realize but it's simple
simple move to play yeah yeah do you
take c5 with the idea that this pawn is
is very weak on d5 now the last lecture
it was about how double pawns maybe not
necessarily a bad thing but in this
position it's not so good for black so
after Bishop takes e5 white goes up upon
and keeps initiative attacking the
bishop on c5 naka plays d6 and now the
Serra plays Bishop to c4 and this was
actually a weird moment I was trying to
analyze a bit earlier because it looks
like Nakamura has a very natural move
here which he didn't play what would you
guys play I can owe you a castle here
that's a possible move yeah yeah Bishop
e6 is probably the most the most natural
move screaming to be played I mean
defend the maid attack the Queen get
some initiative naka played neither
castling nor vision a6 I think he played
a perhaps a worse move he played Queen
e7 so if Bishop e6 were played
I think Queen d3 would be played and
black should actually be doing okay here
at lux still down upon but at least
there's some initiative night before it
would be an option and it could get a
bit it actually could get a bit messy
but I think this is a much better option
for for black after Queen e7 this is
where we'll start to see problems and I
think when when naka played Queen e7
he did not prop acknowledge White's next
move was very simple move Bishop to g5
just developing with tempo f6 was played
and now white to move and I was very
impressed with with White's next move
here because it's just simple but very
strong yeah long castle very nice we
don't care about the bishop we care
about accessing the open files in the
center when white castles queenside you
already got one rook to d1 and you're
preparing to move the other rook to e1
you are leaving the bishop hanging but I
mean the attack is more more valuable
than material and if black were able to
work to take on g5 this would end very
badly white could just take on d6 and
the queen is attacked the e-file is now
open so ricky ones the threat the bishop
is hanging this would be very very bad
so naca did not take on g5 he took on e5
and now white played one more move and
black just resigned anyone want to guess
that a last move here yep rook he1 you
want to say the same thing
okay I believe it was Rick he1 very nice
rock he1 it's incredible because
material is equal and Nakamura just
resigns because there's so many threats
and black who's just completely stuck
White's pieces are fully optimized the
bishops still can't really be taken if
the bishop is taken then just Knight
takes e5 and foxhole position just
falling apart
the King is stuck in the center because
of this open diagonal can't it can't
escape the center and meanwhile let's
say black players and move like Bishop
to b6 white is ready just to take on e5
and just explode the whole Center one
possible line is Knight take e5 but then
after rook take E 5 there's all these
mating ideas coming take E 5 would leaps
at Queen takes Queen f7 with mates so
that's how you be Nakamura in 12 moves I
don't think he was having the best day
sometimes you have to be at the right
place at the right time against the
right player to have a game like this
especially to have a game like this
against a super GM but well it goes to
show no one's invincible and this was
part of a weekly League so it was part
of that was a lot team match and I'm
sure his team was not happy with him
because he's like one of the top players
in the league and to lose in 12 moves is
not the most encouraging thing for a
team yeah so how about we move on I
think we'll get to a lot of games this
lecture because all the games are very
short like this so let's go on I think
I'd like to show a game that I played
this was about a year ago I was playing
against a wgm in Spain name is Jana
Belen and she's actually she holds a
position at Fida I think she's a feed a
medical officer and she's played I think
many Olympians for England if I'm not
mistaken but this game I got the better
of her she played a an opening where she
played into an opening I think she
wasn't too familiar with
this was last year not this year so last
year I did a bit worse than this year
but this game this is actually one of my
quickest wins ever in recent tournament
play it was nine moves and it was thanks
to some nice opening preparation I have
she didn't prepared too deeply this game
I just prepared an opening that I had a
feeling she wouldn't be so comfortable
with and I'll try and explain kind of
the process I used I knew she played the
the nimzo-indian or Queens Indian which
you guys should know is a d4 opening or
a d4 response to d4 where black usually
plays something like e 6 and B 6 I
looked her up in the database I saw she
had hundreds of games from all over the
years and she she played this
consistently so I guess players like
this who play like this is set up
exclusively I usually like to trick them
a little bit by playing c4 first move
and the difference is after black tries
to accomplish this setup with e 6 or B 6
the plan for white is to play e4 which
wouldn't be possible in these d4 main
lines because I start very early with c4
Knight c3 and essentially what happened
she played b6 I play d4 this was the end
of my preparation
I was already happy here to get this
pawn in advance and then she started
thinking and the issue for black is that
I want to play deep play e5 and just
kick away the night and it's perhaps not
so clear how black should respond to the
threats so she played a move here which
is inferior to the best move so you're
saying d6 is one option for black I will
say d6 is not the best move what did you
say he 5 is the best move and this is
what she should have played what she did
play is d6 and the problem with d6 it's
just it's slow it it's a bit passive to
play especially to play d6 and ease and
be 6 so early
it's usually not the best thing to do
within the first three moves of a chess
game so I just play the most principled
move I didn't really calculate too much
here I just played d4 as it's screaming
to be played and now she she played what
I think is just a losing move of the
game her next move Bishop e7 maybe she
should play
she played pawn c5 and when I had played
d4 I had a I had some idea of this
happening and then when she played c5 I
was so happy that there's some some
tactics about to happen in White's favor
so white to move in this position I'll
give some people a chance to think and
find there's a forcing way to win
material here okay Arjen b5 with the
threat of Queen f3
you wanted to say that too very strongly
and this is a problem with her setup
this actually this exact confirmation
runs into Queen f3 were in many cases
the rook is just trapped on e on 8 there
is like no resource for block to defend
the rook so when I play e5 I have the
double threat of Queen f3 and also
simply to take the knight so now blacks
are in trouble
and here she thought for a bit and she
takes on g4 not wait to move how to
continue okay so you want to trade the
Knights and then play Queen f3 you have
the right idea but the wrong execution
if you play Queen f3 first it could get
a bit messy if black takes on c3 and
maybe it's playable the simplest
approach is to trade Knights first it's
not play out for trade nights and now
this position is really important cuz
Queen of three looks great but there's a
problem with Queen of three now three
runs into D 5 and the rook is saved
so queen d5 so I had to kind of pivot
ideas if I can't trap the rook with
clean up three I can drop it with Queen
z5o take on g7 first that would be a big
mistake because I allow her bishop to
threaten some nasty things to four
convey to so that's only helping black
but Queen d5 immediately I'm now a
winning material so black has one last
hope it's already moved seven meaning uh
winning a lot of material blocks hope is
to trap the Queen if you're watching the
lecture or if you were here for the
lecture the other day we had a game
online where we we won the rook on a
then they got the the Queen trapped and
it was very painful when I went into
this variation I essentially calculated
ahead and saw my queen will be able to
escape so she she played an interesting
attempt to Queen c7 Queen take 8 and
then knight c6 and my next move was
necessary to see ahead of time and after
I played my next move
she just resigned so white to move b4 b4
interesting
I should mention or I should have
mentioned that black wants to play King
d7 in Bishop e7 let's see her idea what
if I play King d7 you would take and
then take it could get a bit messy
because now Bach is threatening this and
this b5 first after King g7 this could
potentially work and then the Queen
could retreat though can I be really
clever and play this oh you would take
and then if King take Queenie Yates Oh
Bishop take yeah the Queen is trapped
but White has no time to take on a seven
because the queen is now defending so
yeah there is a threat of King g7 and
and Bishop e7 so I do want to to open up
the Queen side somehow yeah c5 I can
afford to give away a pawn when I'm up a
rook and when I play c5 I have the very
direct threat of Bishop basics and if if
King g7 is played she actually just
resigned after a c5 but if King g7 this
play I'd be happy to do this where I'm
pinning Knights and I want to take on c6
and it Bishop to g7 I can take on a 7
because the knight is pinned and my
queen will escape and I'll just be up at
rook so this was a pretty satisfying
victory became ended in probably about
half hour and I had lots of time to rest
and and prepare for the next game so
goes to show why tactics are really
important in opening especially in the
line that you're not familiar with
things she just let her guard down from
very early on I played something a bit
offbeat and then
before she played c5 she had to be very
cautious about the potential tactics
let's see how many more games we can get
through let's take a look at the Karpov
game we're gonna see Karpov losing 12
moves
this is a fun one have you guys heard of
Larry Christianson any of the you guys
have heard of him - maybe he's known to
be a very attacking player he played us
championships many years ago before the
field got ridiculously strong and he's
famously know famously known for beating
Karpov in 12 moves
question yeah okay so the opening was
actually a bit shocking for this sort of
length of game because it was a very
kind of quieting it started as a Queen's
Indian and then this is one of like
Karpov bread-and-butter openings like
very positional very solid for black and
eventually went into a hedgehog after
Bishop e7 Knight c3 c5 this is a common
idea which I should point out where
black played Bishop a6 first to deflect
the Queen to c2 so now it's not
supporting the D pawn so when c5 is
played white can't play d5 if the Queen
were still on d1 d5 would be a very
strong move to gain space but with the
Queen on c2 these pawns are being traded
by force so the position is very fine
for luck after take take knight c6 more
trades and then Bishop f4 and I think
this is around where Karpov went a
little bit nuts and play the move which
I don't think can be a good move at
least in hindsight can't be a good move
but before we see that what would you
guys play in this position
Bishop e7 is very possible maybe a can
walk into e5 Arjun mm g5 is interesting
g5 could walk into rook t1 though my h5
is what Karpov fighting which I actually
it's probably an okay move to try and
deflect the Bishop from f4 but the
continuation was was very very bad
if Karpov doesn't want to play 9 h5 I
think another option is just to play d6
then ideas of of Queen c7 Bishop e7 e 5
would be under control and blacken
castle and just got a normal Hedgehog
position but now we'll see Knight h5
Bishop retreats first white doesn't want
a trade night for a bishop or Bishop for
Knights you'll see and this might be an
interesting question
Karpov in this position play the losing
move he played one more move white
played one more move Karpov resigns so I
think in chess it's very important to be
tactically alerts not only for yourself
but for your opponents and to be
unconstant lookout like before you play
a move try and visualize it and then try
and ask yourself what sort of tactics
does apone in half in this case Karpov
guess forgot to do that so does anyone
want to try and find the losing move for
black and only say the losing move don't
say the winning move yeah yeah
Bishop D Bishop d6 good job you found a
losing move there's a d6 misplayed looks
like an interesting move a positional
idea of attacking f4 we know Karpov is
very strong in positional chess
this game has tactics suffer the bits
white to move here if you see it don't
say anything white sand moving win for
those of you who don't see it it's very
important in any position that you
identify the undefended pieces in this
case Black has two glaringly undefended
pieces that are relatively exposed the
non h5 and the bishop on e6 and the key
in this position is double attack so ok
it looks like everyone most everyone is
raising their hand yeah all the way back
QD 1 Queens Rd 1 yes double attack
Karpov missus if you could somehow get
this position against Karpov maybe you
could beat him and when the Grandmaster
loses a minor pieces usually just resign
the ball and he didn't want to fight on
from from this position so this is a
classic one and this is something where
if you miss a tactic in your own games
seeing something like this will
hopefully make you feel better about
yourself so if a former world champion
can walk into something like this
everyone can so any questions about this
this is a relatively simple one let's
look at another one along a similar
theme has it ever happened to me I've
lost games quickly I don't know about
that quickly at least in tournament play
maybe online play I've lost very quickly
my opponents well I just showed you one
game though there's been some quick
games but usually a bit longer than 15
poof's
9news actually actually my very first
tournament I lost me in four moves
I was devastating before move checkmate
that was back when I I didn't know much
about chess so but then after it
happened it never happened again so
that's how I learned I was eight but I
was so devastated because I didn't
realize it was possible to lose that
that quickly
I was just depressing okay next team
thomas reich against emulous Pavlovic
anyone heard of either of these players
you heard of pablovich okay I've heard
of him - I don't know exactly who he is
I think he's from Serbia he's a
grandmaster this game he lost very
quickly against someone low-rated than
him and it was essentially an opening
trap so we're gonna zoom through the
opening c3 Sicilian and this opening can
come come up in a lot of like amateur
play I think it's a very simple opening
for white to play where white just grabs
the centre very early and this is a
common response from lack to tab the
Queen on d5 and to try and apply
pressure on the plunge for so in this
game both players develop nothing too
unusual yet but Bishop e3 is a nice move
by White's because white wants to just
take on c5 wide is threatening to win a
pawn here and black is essentially
provoked to take on d4 which makes white
happy because after the pawns get traded
white is now ready to play Knight c3
and attack the queen with tempo so in
this position that black black went
terribly wrong and play the move which
looks like a nice positional move black
wanted to put as much pressure as
possible on the d4 pawn
and he played you want to suggest the
poof it's a losing move e5 probably not
a great move but block played an even
worse smooth ken west Bishop g4 it's
probably a good move
yes knight c6 knight c6 probably isn't
good because might c3 and d5 but black
played an even worse smooth arjun f5 is
really weird but blacks still played
probably a much worse move that's
probably the worst movement position
it's not green take a - let me show you
the yeah did you want to say something
now h6 was played and now why it hasn't
move here to win material by force and
some people see it right away I will say
it's very similar to the idea from last
game from the Karpov game where Cobra of
had undefended pieces or targets in this
case there's two very very big targets
for a white to attack of course the
Queen could be considered as targets but
also the bishop on c8 is a target it's
not defended and then I'm in h6 is a
target because it's attacked once and
defended once so it could potentially be
attacked again what you should look for
in this position is a double attack
White's a move how to win material yeah
Vinnie Queen see you want very nice
everyone wanted to say Queen c1 very
good very subtle this is a very like
kind of quiet move you just move the
Queen 1 square over and you're utilizing
the whole board some very nice geometry
happening here and even like very strong
players can sometimes neglect to see the
whole board like sometimes you're just
focused on the King side or just focus
on the Queen side but you have to see
especially in open positions you have to
see the sort of geometry and in this
case yeah white's is just winning a
minor piece and lock just resigns
so that was 8 moves
Jessa's tough let's move on okay I was
debating whether to show the next game
actually the next game I'm gonna show
came to mind right before the lecture II
started but I want to show it just to
illustrate a complete like brain lapse
and maybe some of you remember this this
was played in st. Louis it was a first
round of the 2012 US Championship yeah
playing white is Grandmaster Alexander
strip Winsky playing black is
Grandmaster Alexander on a shock to two
American players hopefully you guys have
heard of at least one of them hopefully
both of them this game I wanted to show
because it kind of illustrates why you
should be very careful especially in the
first round of a tournament and you
should always do some kind of insanity
check where you're just checking the
move before you make it just to make
sure you're seeing you were here were
you in like watching like in the playing
room yeah it was pretty shocking so it
started as a Carroll con Knight c3 d5
and Knight f3 this is what we call the
two Knights attack against the CARICOM
it's actually one of my favorite
variations to play as white this game
honest I played the most common move
Bishop g4 H 3 and then Bishop take f3
sometimes that's have been unusual for
the Bishop to trade the Knights so early
but in this case oh it's not the one you
were thinking of in this case black gets
kind of a solid position he trades the
bishop because black gets the pawns on
light squares and this is a nice
position idea if you're going to put all
your pawns on lights where is sometimes
it makes sense to trade off your lights
for addition slow game continues g3 and
it looks like white is just trying to be
solid just play Bishop g2 and Castle
nothing wrong so far I think in this
position honest look maybe not yet 97
was played Queen e2
on the ship was already maybe
considering some aggression like maybe
considering Knights c5 so the Queen
retreated to e2 d4 and your honest look
was being quite aggressive Knight be one
and now h5 so some very early pawn
lunges by black the idea of h5 is to
potentially play h4 and try and create
some weakness in White's pawn structure
so white played h4 himself and then
honestok played another kind of
ambitious maybe someone unexpected move
have you seen this game before no do you
want to suggest it sorry g5 rather than
developing the pieces he's just pushing
his pawns maybe the the smaller children
here should close their eyes but g5 is
actually a nice positional move because
some idea is to play g4 and 95 and and
maybe fixate on the weakness on f3 so
white played perhaps a natural response
H take g5 and now Queen take g5 and now
before we go any further I just want to
see what people would suggest here is
whites and what would you play in this
position feel free to suggest to move
and we'll see how many people would
suggest the move that was played yes
Bishop g2 Bishop g2 D 3 D 3 D 3 okay so
three of you played the same move as a
grandmaster normally that's a good thing
in this case it was a very bad thing so
well he completed the move he played d3
even if he touched the pawn and then
realized he has to play it's only legal
move with a D pawn and the funny thing
is he played d3 saw that his Bishop is
not defended and then just resigns on
his own turn usually you resign or on
his opponents turn usually you resign on
your own turn in this case he just saw
that Queen takes c1 is hunting I was
very tragic to start the u.s.
championship by making such very bad
blunder but it's like from a
psychological standpoint when your
Bishop is on c1 like this you just
assume it's defended sometimes you make
false assumptions and it was defended
just a few moves ago before Knight B 1
it was defended by the rook but the fact
the knight is on B 1 and the Queen is no
longer on D 1 uses the bishop just
undefended so you can kind of see a
common theme at least with this game in
the previous games its undefended pieces
are very important to identify even very
strong players make very bad blunders so
that's why when you play a stronger
player you always have to realize that
they're capable of making blunders even
the best in the world yeah next game let
me see which one yeah Carlsen Caruana
do you know this
we're probably for this game we're
probably gonna go straight to the end if
I'm not mistaken this might be car
Juana's quickest defeats in at least
recent years in the last decade maybe
how long was this game this game was 11
moves and Carlsen 1 which is not a good
sign going into the World Championship
but okay this game was played in 2014 so
hopefully Caruana has learned his lesson
since then it was it was a French no
wonder he lost so not too much respect
for the French then you play the French
and you don't have respect for it okay
so we'll see that this is a topical line
with c5 and Knight f3 and okay the pawns
get traded not f6 I will say I don't
know too much of the theory here I know
it's supposed to be relatively equal
with good preparation from black but
Knight b5 is a very ambitious move just
aiming for the the fork of course
Caruana sees the the fourth threat plays
96 the game continues Knight to c3 Queen
d8 and now a three by carp by Carlsen
which i think is a really nice
prophylactic move as white you might be
inclined here just to complete
development but when a3 is played he's
realizing that perhaps a bishop wanted
to go to b4 and after a three now both
the bishop and the knight are perhaps
fighting for the c5 square so he's
making it a bit more uncomfortable for
for black he also might have ideas of
playing B for himself just to take away
the c5 square so Bishop e7 was played
Queen f3
and now Caruana castles and maybe now
some of you realize that castling is a
massive blunder white to move win a
piece simple tactics yes duck Bishop
take a 6 right because there's a pin
that's incredible like Viviano Caruana
number 2 in the world but i think
sometimes in the in some circumstances
where you're playing a very strong
player and it splits and you're moving
quickly it's still possible to
overlooked simple tactics in this case
when Queen f3 is played it was sort of
disguised as maybe positional move maybe
there's ideas of Queen g3 and you just
forget to look for the tactical threat
that's why after every move your
opponent plays you should always ask
yourself what's the threat or are there
tactics
we're gonna move on to a sheriff being
sure of black against fiddler two very
well-known GM's fiddler known for his
what chess top 20 for commentary super
GM is he coming to st. Louis did he
qualify for the grand chess to her no
that's kind of sad and there's no
wild-card spot okay he's doing
commentary yeah he either like if
there's a huge Herman he's either
playing in it or doing commentary for it
and he's very well versed in the opening
but in this game now this was 2004 so
maybe he's grown since then this game
was not so impressive by him efore and
we're gonna see another French but this
time we're gonna see the black side of
the French we're gonna see black win
very quickly and we'll see a line which
perhaps isn't the most common but is
really interesting and maybe someone
maybe some of you can use this for blitz
if if you're looking for something
simple to play at least in this
variation the advance variation so how
many people here actually play the
French is black some of you a lot of you
okay
and in the advance variation of course
you know the idea for black is to try
and take down the center let me ask the
French players here what's so the worst
thing about this variation for black yes
your lights for admission yeah also
maybe the space deficit - well I swear
Bishop is usually the worst piece has
the hardest time finding it's a good
square in the position so from very
early on we're gonna see how share of
solves this problem c5 c3
and now Queen b6 now I would think most
people would play knight c6 first am I
correct
at least of French players Queen b6 is a
small nuance black is not committing the
knight to c6 because there's an idea as
we'll see after Knight f3 the idea is to
play Bishop g7 and then immediately go
for Bishop e5 and trade off Black's
worst piece for one of White's best
pieces when White has all the pawns on
dark squares least the center pawns the
lights where Bishop is White's best
piece so this is actually a really nice
positional idea for for black now one of
the downsides with this plan is that
black does waste or it does use a lot of
time to execute this maneuver and
there's a lot of lot of theory around
this line and if light is well-prepared
it should be good for whites but as
we'll see in this game fiddler was not
super prepared question so it is White's
move here
a4 is possible maybe a force playable
sometimes an issue with a4 is it weakens
of e4 square and these lines after I
take take before is weak because why
can't play a3 and this is probably a
good version of some kind of mainline
advanced variation yeah
there's some idea yeah knight c6 2a v 2
b 3 a 4 is a bit weakening so I will
show after Bishop e2 and Bishop to b5
there are some options for whites I
think the most aggressive option and if
you play this as white it's probably
something to look into is this kind of
wild move pawn c4 where you're trying to
open up the center it maybe even
sacrifice a pawn to take advantage of
blacks kind of slow development and the
fact that white is ready to castle very
soon and play Knight c3 so this would
probably be my recommendation what
fiddler played was D takes e5 which I
have a feeling is not a great move I
will show it just another option just to
demonstrate this idea for black if I
plays a natural King side castling black
would like to take on e to take on e2
and play Queen a6 and just trade Queens
can get a very positional game where if
the Queen's got traded in the French
structure and the lights for bishops got
traded black is usually happy to to
build up pressure on the Queen side but
let's say with the game D takes e5
Bishop takes e5 and now a very
surprising move from White's pawn d4
very bold very brave move now it's a
playable move but we're gonna see it
leads to a lot of messiness why this is
essentially asking for Bishop take f2
which happens now the idea for white is
he sacrifices upon to try and take
advantage of the fact that this Bishop
and the Queen they're kind of glued
together and the bishop doesn't really
have any great squares and there's some
threats here for white we're okay white
just wants to take on d5 and if Bishop
take e2 Queen take you to the bishops is
trapped
so plaque has to come up with a move
here block played Bishop to d7 and I
think at the time this is a novelty
where he's he's maintaining the tension
there's no way for a white to chop the
bishop right away and there's no way for
a white to kick the Queen so for the
time being black keeps the Bishop
defended and doesn't lose material so
white played Queen to d2 the threat is
to play Bishop d3 and trap the bishop on
f2 so now a question how to play is
black how can you not lose material and
find a resource to not only defend but
create some attack yes Knight what not
h6 very good I think this is only move I
grabbed this game from somewhere in the
database and it did come with
annotations and whenever you see this
box next to Knight h6 it means only move
and sometimes people will say Knight h6
box that means simply means when we move
only move which means any other move
would be losing for black essentially in
this case side you have 96 is to play
Knight g4 create some resources so h3
knife f5 this time is black playing
knife f5 and Knight g3 would be a
devastating checkmates even after Bishop
d3 this is still mate g4 is probably the
best move and then black will win the
exchange yeah so h3 wasn't played Bishop
d3 was played apparently this was a
really bad mistake because it allows
black a lot of initiative white was just
trying to continue with the original
plan I think it would have been better
for white to play some other move there
were some other options e4 would have
been interesting idea of playing c5 but
there there's many other lines that we
can delve into which we won't just for
the sake of time let's see how
how white lost in just a few more moves
Knight g4 is played black is already
doing very well because III is very weak
and keep in mind black is up upon here
and black has attack there's now ideas
of Bishop III maybe even 93 and white is
under major pressure so white played a
play the blunder here
Korena force should have been played but
white played Queen g5 and now I really
have black played one more move and
white resigns so black to move and find
the the crushing move which makes white
resign
yes Bishop h4 there's a base for your
threatening the Queen and you're
threatening mate but Queen tickets for
and I think I'm maybe misspoke the next
move was not the last move but it's it's
really the key idea in the position
maybe you guys saw it yeah Bishop g3
it's an idea but there's a stronger move
yeah
Bishop g1 a Bishop II 1 maybe King take
e1 the King can run Queen Queen f2 King
d1 so in a lot of these lines where
you're removing the bishop like Bishop
g3 or Bishop to g1 there's there's ways
for the King to run to like e to and
there's a much more crushing response
yeah there should be 5 I think a lot of
you were focused on mating on f2 but
there's an additional mating idea where
if Bishop take b5 Queen jb5 is just
ending in mates you saw that nice job
Ken West I mean while black is running
Nathan 1 and he made them one threat
it's a forcing move and the difference
we'll see here
after see for now Bishop g3 and now if
the White King runs away I should know
Bishop g3 I think was the final move of
the game spoiler just resigned here if
Queen take g4 or HH Sheikh g3 can wean
off to his mate because both pieces are
supporting f2 it's a very nice clearance
move if he runs to out to e2
now the idea is to play queen f2 King d1
and now the bishop has access to a 4
Bishop takes c2 would be the final meet
I do have a file of of some more
miniatures which I think what I'll do is
put together a study on me chess we'll
share it in the video description so
people can see these games and can look
at look at the analysis add your own
analysis and open
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]